[APPLAUSE]
NAT DUCA: Hey everybody.
Wow.
Thanks for coming out.
I guess you're going to have to
listen to me for a little bit.
Yeah, I tend to feel like I'm in
the graphics hacker mood today.
So what I do, when they let me
out of my cage to come here is,
I try to explain what the Chrome
graphics team, and basically
the Blink engineering team
that works on smoothness-- what
we're trying to do, what
we're thinking about.
There's sort of this chasm
between us implementers
and the real world,
because like I said,
they don't let us
out of our cages.
I've been working on the
graphics stack in Chrome
for about four years, and
we've originally titled this,
'The Pursuit of 60fps
Everywhere,' because we've been
trying to get 60fps on
MacBook, 60fps on Android,
60fps on old
Windows XP machines,
and that's a nightmare.
We've been trying to do, when
you have some old nasty sites;
a CuteOverload.com, which is
just a pile of animated .gifs,
and we're trying
to make that 60fps.
And at the same
time, we're trying
to make some nice mobile
apps that people are making,
that are gorgeous,
run at 60fps too.
And about last year,
we started thinking,
this is kind of crazy.
We're putting a lot of
energy architecturally
in dealing with sites
like CuteOverload,
and we're not thinking
a lot about mobile.
Or we're thinking
a lot about it,
but when we look
at are folks who
are trying to make mobile
content, we started noticing,
this hurts.
These people are
in severe anguish.
And so what we decided is,
let's really double down
on this mobile story.
How do we make 60fps of
mobile content an achievable
and sort of reliable reality?
And that's been a bit of a
journey over the last year.
We really started
refocusing and saying,
no, no, that's a terrible
desktop site-- screw it.
Let's make mobile
really amazing.
So this is a graphic stack
talk, so no graphics talk
is going to be complete without
mentioning the layers word.
And so what I want to do is,
do a really quick, deep--
or a really quick
crash course on layers.
And then move on to
what we're thinking
about rendering and
60fps in the future.
There's a lot of material
up on JankFree.org
that you all can go read.
There's a great talk by our
Paul, from I/O this year,
that sort of explains
how to get 60fps
on all the browsers,
using layers, using things
like will-change,
using transforms.
I'm going to do
short form of it,
but if you really kind
of feel blown away
by what I end up talking
about, go to JankFree,
check out those talks; they
really put it in perspective
for you.
So layers.
These are two pictures
from Polymer.org content.
The left is the quiz app, the
right is the paper sampler.
And this is the way the browser
sees those pages, tilted,
using our tool called
FrameViewer, in order
to see the layers in the page,
versus what the user sees.
What the browser is
doing every frame,
is it's looking at your
Dom any time you change it,
and it's going, eh,
well, that's scrolling,
and that has an animation
on it, so I'm gonna, I
think they're going to
move that in the future.
It's sort of guessing.
And all it does is,
we sort of assume
that painting and the
rendering, and the HTML stack
is going to be horribly slow.
And so we take a picture of
whatever part of the page
we think is going to
move around together.
We take a picture of it.
We call that a layer--
think Photoshop layers.
And we shovel that off to the
GPU, and we keep it there.
And so unsurprisingly,
if you go and muck
around with an element
that has been lucky enough
to get a layer, and you start
moving it around with just two
properties, transform
and opacity-- if you just
do those two things, then you're
hitting the absolute fastest
path that a browser has to
moving something around.
But there's this whole problem
of, well if you have a layer.
So in the yesteryear,
there were a lot of hacks;
everybody's seen the Webkit
transform translateZ(0) kind
of incantation, which
is exactly content free.
It means nothing, right?
In the sort of
spirit of say what
you mean, what we did early
last year after realizing
that this whole thing is a mass,
is we worked with Mozilla--
or more appropriately,
Mozilla worked with us,
to create this will-change spec.
And what happens in
the will-change spec,
is you say to us, I'm going
to change this element left.
Or I'm going to change
this element to transform.
And then what we do
is, we factor that
into our calculation--
what should get a layer?
And then based on that, you
usually get what you request.
So if you hint
something as having
a changing left, and it's
big, you'll get a layer.
This is really, really
important for performance,
as you can kind of imagine.
If you don't hint the browser
about what's going to change,
then you get basically
a flat world.
Your whole Dom
becomes one layer,
and any time anything starts
moving, either you'll get lucky
and it pops out, and it
becomes its own layer.
Or just, it submarines
through, and the whole layer
starts repaint storming,
and kittens cry,
and you don't get a space.
Anyway, with
will-change, everything
pops out to its own layer,
and goodness results.
So this is one of
the Polymer demos.
And the thing that
I wanted-- I'm not
going to do an
extensive demo of this,
but what characterizes
sort of these demos,
is that they're nice and
responsive, even on your phone.
You know-- I don't know
what I'm typing here,
but each one of
these things that's
moving around as I do it,
you can guarantee it's
will-change to the gills.
What we're doing is,
every single piece of it,
is annotated with the
will-change annotation
that best fits
that type of motion
that it's going to undergo.
So I actually want to show you
a little trace here of that,
in the actual FrameViewer.
So you saw those things
that I was showing before.
This is sort of how the user
sees it-- not tilted obviously.
And this is how the browser
sees it; each one of those
is a layer.
And so if we advance
through time,
what you'll end up seeing is
this yellow dot should grow,
you know-- after a stall to
give me a heart attack, right?
So you know, this
yellow dot grows,
and you see the whole
rest of the world
is completely stationary.
Just this yellow dot is growing.
And what you'll see at the
end is-- there's that button,
see it appearing?
And then finally the
whole thing settles down,
all the old Dom goes away,
and we've got our final image.
And that's a really
good scripted animator--
well, not scripted, but a
coordinated animation, where
we've got everything
coming in nice and smooth,
each layer is being transformed,
it's 60fps, happiness results.
So layers, they're your friend;
will-change, super important.
Hop over to JankFree for a
lot more information on them.
But what I really want to
talk about today is why?
When was the meeting?
I missed it-- where
we sat down and we
said, the way that you
will be 60fps on the web is
through layers.
And the way that you will
make things fast on the web
is by turning off all the
web, and having two properties
that you can touch;
translate and--
or transform, and opacity.
I missed that meeting.
But man, that's
that a weird trade.
Right?
We've got all this great
expressiveness in the web,
and we can only
use two properties.
Now if you ask
around, you'll get
a lot of answers
for why this is.
I'd like to give you my personal
interpretation-- I'd, almost
certainly wrong-- but here
goes: we, browser implementers,
make our bread and butter
from browsing websites, just
plain old websites.
You've all been to probably
a dozen websites today,
sort of mundane, you know--
maybe they were mobile
optimized, but the vast
majority of page views aren't.
So there's these big
sites that are designed
for a big powerful computer,
that's probably plugged in,
and you're shoving it into
your tiny little phone.
And you're asking
it to load quickly,
you're asking it to scroll,
even while it's still
the loading-- maybe
you're going to pinch it,
so that you can tap
a link and move on.
And this has been the
focus of browser vendors
since these mobile
phones came out.
So Chrome was madly-- our
team was madly just trying
to make Chrome a
decent web browser when
viewing these pages.
So why is this a problem?
I took the Meetup desktop site,
and I shoved it onto a Nexus 5,
and I profiled it.
And the way I profiled it
was with DevTools these days,
is coming with a new
version of the timeline.
This looks like
plain old DevTools,
but in the Experiments tab,
there's now this fancy little
thing called 'Timeline on trace
events.' And what that does is,
it gives you this button.
And then you have about tracing,
type displays, and about
tracing type data,
right in your thing.
Now why does this matter?
It makes it really easy to
compute a table like this,
which says, during
this period of time,
this is exactly
where your time went.
Now when you talk
about smoothness,
like when you talk
about page load,
you care about how much
time is going where.
But we don't have a
network to contend with.
So all we care about is how much
CPU was being used right now,
and how do we make it smaller?
The Meetup desktop site has
literally 2000 milliseconds
of page load activity.
And then even when it's static,
even when it's just completely
you're not touching it and then
you just scroll up and down,
it does another 250 milliseconds
or whatever-- 190 milliseconds
of work, every
second when I scroll.
I don't know what it's doing,
it's doing some jQuery thing.
But like, you'd
think-- you'd think
nothing's changing, right?
I go to the stupid thing,
and I scroll it up and down.
It's not changing, but
that thing is literally
using 150 milliseconds every
second, to do something.
And this is the world that
a browser vendor comes into,
which is lots of content
that people really
need to see right?
But a web page that, either
because it's loading,
or because somebody's script
is having a bad hair day,
it is unresponsive.
So it's not acceptable
for us to just
have you when you go to
this site on your phone,
just be completely
unresponsive--
like, oops, sorry,
jQuery is thinking,
you can't scroll right now.
Layers are the defense
mechanism that we came up with,
to deal with an adversarial web.
Let me do a demo to
try to explain this.
So bare with.
We've got, everybody can
learn my unlock code.
We've got a simple page that
is already got the check box.
We've got a simple page,
that scrolls up and down.
This is a simple demo, OK?
Would we all agree that
this is mostly smooth?
It's sticking to my finger-ish.
And then I'm going to
press this jank button.
And what the jank
button is going to do,
is it's just going
to do a set time out,
that literally just
pegs the JS for, I
think it's 200
milliseconds randomly.
And this is to simulate
that sort of situation
of the jQuery thing kicking
off and being cranky.
It's still smooth, right?
What this is doing is,
we're using these layers
to compensate for the
jank and basically hide
the fact that they page
is being evil from you,
so that you get a
good experience.
And if you don't believe
me, we can measure,
measure, measure--
pop open this,
take a timeline
recording, and I'm
going to pop over to my screen.
Hands going everywhere.
This is the trace of
what this poor app is
doing in JavaScript, right?
A 300 millisecond
jank, but it was
completely smooth to my finger.
OK.
So I'm a Chrome
hacker, so I now have
to put up an
architecture diagram.
Because we've gone a
whole what-- five minutes
without one.
This is the grossly
oversimplified way
that I see most web
browsers existing last year,
and really this year too.
The composite step
sits at the end
of the pipeline,
that has your layers.
It also receives all the
input from your finger
or from your mouse, and
it drives the screen.
And when you scroll, it receives
the input, updates the layers,
and directly drives the screen.
And that whole left
side; JavaScript
getting the on scroll,
recalc and layout
running and response, maybe
your set timeout firing
and changing the div,
and doing the background
or whatever it is, all of
that can go super, super slow,
and it will scroll, right?
So we've optimized
really, really hard core
in the direction to make
that scroll responsive.
There's this sort of trade
that we've made implicitly
in hyper-optimizing
for smoothness, which
is, you don't really
reliably find out
about the fact that
we scrolled the page.
Sure, you can
listen to onscroll,
but it's not prevent
defaultable, right?
It's kind of late, right?
If you try to do
something in response
to an onscroll, and
position something,
then everything sort
of jitters around.
You don't get any notice
of like touch events
once scrolling begins-- it's
all just sort of bolted on.
Like we sort of send
a little message over
from the compositor
side of things,
all the way over to JSA, and
hey, we scrolled, if you cared.
But we were 60fps.
And this is the
architecture we have.
And so there's this value
proposition that we said,
that was we gave you 60fps,
aren't you really happy?
And having worked on
this architecture,
and getting it working,
we are pretty darn excited
that we could give you 60fps
on these terrible devices.
But what we're
saying in exchanges
is, if you wanted to do anything
as an application that's
compelling; you want the fancy
drawer, or the pull to refresh,
you must represent all this as
a CSS animation or as scrolling.
If you just remove
the architecture
diagram, because those
are boring anyway.
And you look at these
two things together,
you kind of see that
there's this dissonance.
This is not a great
value proposition.
Give me a browser that maybe
isn't a 100% efficient,
but for the love of God,
doesn't do this crazy stuff.
We want the a
rational web browser,
because that's the
one that empowers
developers to do great things.
And this weird thing
with the scroll bypassed
that goes back to the
sometimes, blah blah blah,
that nobody understands except
like three Chrome engineers
and a couple at Mozilla,
et cetera, doesn't cut it.
So we have this whole
crisis of faith last year,
and we shouted at each
other in a Googly way.
So everybody was smiling.
And then we decided OK,
let's do some stuff.
Chrome 37 really is-- we've
been making changes on trunks--
so Chrome 31, 32,
33-- all of those
have come out with little
bits of the improvements.
37 is where a lot of things
just sort of happened
to come together.
And so it's a very
exciting release for us,
inasmuch as Chrome,
Chromies get excited
about a particular provision.
We think it's a lot better.
And I tried to do a laundry
list of things that change it.
And the thing I'd like you to
think about as you hear this,
is well, yes, this is going
to be Chrome- specific,
but the thing is, start
challenging those assumptions
that maybe you've got built
in to you of oh, my god,
I could only do
these two things.
Start going, hey, does
this change that demo
that I tried the other day?
Maybe I'll try it again.
Maybe this'll be fun this time.
So the first thing we
did was we moved in
and put it where it
belongs, on the left, here.
Just put it where it is.
JavaScript says that
there's window.onscroll.
Let's try to get the world
back to a place where
window.onscroll
fires, and it fires
after you have
window.touchbegin,
for instance, right?
And maybe we could even make
preventDefault behave sanely.
So we started doing
that, and Chrome 37
includes this new
touch model, and it's
very close to
Mozilla's actually.
We don't think it's 100% there,
but it's a lot more rational,
as far as input is
in the right place.
And sort of related to
that, we changed the timing
in all the machinery that drives
both requestanimationframe
onscroll.
It used to be that if
you position stuff--
I alluded to this-- if you
position stuff in onscroll,
and you tried to scroll
at the same time,
you'd see them sort of
never quite line up.
And we did a lot of tweaks, so
that if you stay within a 16
millisecond budget, you can
do onscroll positioning.
So you can do sort of a
ghetto position sticky now,
or a ghetto pull
to refresh, if you
pair the input
changes we've done.
Or a couple other things.
And we're aiming for
even bigger there.
But this is sort
of the first thing.
Now we also did just-- I
guess you could call it
a spring cleaning of the code.
When we began the
project, about a year ago,
we were really worried that like
the web was insolvably fast.
Un-solvably fast?
Slow.
Basically we were worried
that CSS is algorithmically
impossible to do at real time.
Because in CSS, you have a thing
where you have n selectors,
and m elements, and
you have to sort
of cross product them to
figure out what matches.
And this is just
sort of n times m,
it's a big number-- oh, my god.
And similar around layout; like
layout has so many intricacies;
floats, you know,
line management--
like it's just hairy stuff.
And so we were really
worried that this second box,
the recalc would just
be-- and the layout--
would be impossible
to do at 60fps.
And we dug and we dug.
And we had a couple
crises of faith.
And we basically found that
the reason that this was slow,
in all the Chromes in all
the webkits that preceded us,
was because of some bugs.
And just some unoptimized code,
and just sort of the accretion
a big software.
And when we fixed
it, we found five,
ten-- we found
optimizations and winds that
were just kind of mind blowing.
And we did the same in
the compositing stack
and found lot of
performance winds too.
So this spring cleaning that
we did essentially, just
sped up Chrome's sort of,
two of these critical paths,
by-- for us, for
graphics engineers,
are some pretty neat numbers.
So we did one final thing, which
is oh, my god, fast painting.
So if you've studied
painting, and you've
studied hitting 60fps, we always
say, oh, my gosh, don't paint.
Whatever you do,
turn off your-- do
everything you can
to avoid a repaint.
Because repaints
are catastrophic.
And you know, that's true.
But it also stinks.
Right?
Because you want to paint.
You might want to
show something new,
and then you got
to paint, right?
So why does that have
to be a mandatory jank?
So the technique that we
wanted to bring out to fix this
is GPU rasterization.
GPU rasterization
is just where we
use the GPU to fill in
the pixels on the screen,
before we make the layer.
So we've got a layer, and we
have to fill in the pixels
in it.
So if you have a white
layer and a border,
then that's a draw--
like a WebGL draw,
with the triangles
for the white,
and then some more triangles
to represent the border.
For many cases,
like simple content,
the GPU is way, way, way
faster, than we can ever
do with the CPU.
But it's sort of
falls over, when
you start throwing
like Gmail at it.
And there's this
other pesky problem,
which is like, when you used
to run this on an old Samsung
phone, the phone
would just reboot
when you went to certain pages.
Which gives you a really
bad page load score.
So we were really conflicted.
It's like well, this
is so much faster,
but the time that
we're going to need
to get this working perfectly
on every device, for every piece
of content-- make it
really good for Gmail,
and really good
for mobile content,
is heat death of the universe.
So we settle on something
that is kind of awkward,
but gets the content-- the
capability into people's hands.
And we call that
the Magic Viewport.
If you put this Viewport
on your content,
and you have a phone that
we've enabled-- we've tested
and we've verified that
your phone doesn't reboot,
which is a good thing;
we will give you
GPU rasterization instead
of the CPU rasterizing.
And I have the understated
sentence; goodness results.
So, demo.
It's not a very interesting
demo, per tradition.
So what I'm going to do
is show you the content,
and then we'll come back to my
screen to show you the numbers.
So this is just--
what we're going
to do is we're going to look
at this piece of content, which
is just an image, that
is animating its width.
There's no transformed
kerfuffle here at all.
We are literally animating the
width and height of an image.
If you look really
carefully, you
can see there's a drop shadow
on the right of the image, that
stays nice and crisp
as it animates up.
There's a one pixel
border around the image.
This is the kind
of thing that you
can't do with scale animations.
And you see stuff like
this that's prettier
when you tap a contact
icon on a phone,
and the icon grows to be a
picture of a person, right?
It looks gorgeous,
and you ooh and ah.
That requires
repainting every frame.
And this is something that
is really, really costly,
in the old painting
architecture.
In Chrome 37, you
can measure this
without the Magic Viewport, and
what you'll see, is these paint
times are obscene.
So we're looking at
50, 60 milliseconds.
That is not a frame make, right?
16, that's three or four frames.
Now it looks
decently smooth when
you see it on the projector.
But it's just, where we're
paying dearly for this look.
So if we-- somewhere in here, I
have the Magic Viewport.html--
and the only difference in this
is we put in that incantation.
And so if you look at this
one-- I'm not going to show you,
it's the same darn
thing on my screen.
The trace looks completely
different, right?
Those bars are
much, much smaller,
and everything is hitting 60.
The frames are 16 milliseconds.
This is really good.
And what's happening
here is the GPU
in this case is just killing
it, as far as performance goes.
So the Magic Viewport enables
sort of this future technology
that we eventually want to
see throughout the Chrome
ecosystem.
And this gives you
early access to it,
if you want to be sort of dog
fooding it, or trying it out.
Now of course, there is this
restriction on your machine.
But if you want to do
some experimentation,
you could force
GPU rasterization,
and it'll turn on.
OK.
So pause.
We've been opinionated about--
this is kind of weird that we
have to do all these layers.
And then we talked
about what we've
been doing so far to hit 60fps.
And the message that I
really try to communicate
is, we actually think
we're getting somewhere,
where you can actually
hit 60fps pretty easily,
and not kill yourself.
Now if you want to be guaranteed
that you'll hit 60fps,
you still want to invoke
the old transform,
translate, be very
careful mechanisms.
But in Chrome 37 and
probably much more
as we proceed with our
relentless update cycle,
you will see that
you can run each
and every one of these
stages and have them firing
every frame, and still
totally hit 60fps.
And what we're working
toward is a way
that you can think
about performance,
in sort of a completely
rational way.
Instead of having
this weird voodoo that
like Paul in the back
understands, and I sort of you
know, quarterback
coach that-- we
want a model that's completely
understandable, and everybody
could fit in their head.
And this is sort of
what we've got in 37.
There are two parts to
the performance model.
First, you want to think
about what pipeline stage
you're going to trigger running.
So if you change the width
of something, then be recalc
and layout system's
going to run,
and then it's going to
trigger everything down
in the pipeline.
But if you change
transform and opacity, only
to the bottom stage
of the composite stage
is going to run.
Now you'd think, hey, this
has been the case in browses
since forever.
Except bugs.
Big browsers, big software,
and it turns out that
even recently, when
you mutated opacity,
if you did in the wrong
way, you would actually
cause the whole darn
stack from recalc to run.
And you'd end up with
repaints, and you'd
be sitting there going,
I don't understand
what's going on here.
So we're cleaning this up.
We're making this part of the
mental model completely clean.
That if you mutate one
of these properties,
you will get a predictable
set of things that run.
And CSS triggers lets you
sort of reason about that.
There's another
have of this model
that we're working
on too; which is
to give you sort of
this relatively easy
to grab a hold of mental
model, for how long
each of the steps of
the pipeline takes.
Now the reason for this is,
once you could say, oh yeah,
composite is proportional
to such and such,
you can build up a budget in
your head of how much time you
want to spend in each
one of these stages,
when you want to burn
out your 16 milliseconds.
So you might say, I
want to spend most
my time in recalc and paint,
but I want light composite.
And once you understand what
causes each of these stages
to run long, you can then tweak
your content to control it.
So the composite,
for example, is
proportional to the
number of layers.
So if you have about
30 layers, you're
looking at three
milliseconds-ish on Chrome,
per frame of cost.
And if you double
the layer count,
then it'll go up, et cetera.
Painting is basically
proportional to how much
area-wise you change,
times what's in it.
So a white square is going
to be quite a bit cheaper
than a square full
of all sorts of text,
that has a drop
shadow, and a border
and a filter on top of it.
It's pretty straightforward.
So you know, a solid
div, sort of free-ish.
And of course, if you
have GPU rasterization,
you get sort of
this extra boost,
that hopefully we'll give
to everybody really soon.
Recalc and layout is
an area that we're just
beginning to poke at, so I don't
have a really clear message
here.
What we do know is that you
definitely shouldn't style
thrash.
So you shouldn't set
the styles on something,
and then try to read them back,
by getting computed style.
If you do that, then you're
basically killing yourself.
And a really common
mistake we see people do,
is in trying to make web-- make
CSS transitions work for them,
we see people having
to force recalc,
and everything goes to hell.
The fix for this is
to use web animations.
It's fantastic.
But if you eliminate sort
of the basic mistakes of not
thrashing, then the
mental model that I
think we should use for
now is, that the cost
of recalc and
layout is basically
proportional to the number
of elements in your dock--
not visible elements, total.
So if your Dom is
1,000 elements, which
we think is about a good
match for mobile phones,
you can run substantial
portions of recalc
without all of a sudden
falling in to no fps territory.
And of course if you
reduce that count,
you'll go even faster,
and so on and so forth.
What's right out is a 10,000
element Dom on a mobile phone,
just don't do it.
Start figuring out
how to reduce that.
Use Viewporting, use
whatever you want.
But keep your
element count down,
because the purple--
the purple stage
is proportional
to element count.
And finally, contrary to some
really weird press articles
and research articles
so-called, JavaScript
is ridiculously fast.
And GC is rarely a problem.
The web is not slow
because GC is the problem.
The web is slow because we
didn't optimize recalc, layout,
paint and composite.
And because the
model's kind of broken
about only being
able to do layers.
GC, it's in the noise.
When we do see
JavaScript run long,
the few times I've
really dug into it,
it's usually just
because the JavaScript
is making a lot
of Dom, that it's
going to append to the
world's free rendering.
And we know the
solution for that.
That's to use
templates if you can.
Because templates
allow us to advertise
costs, and do
things a lot faster.
We know a lot about
the composite step.
We want to firm up
this sort of model,
and make it really
easy to communicate.
This is the first time
we've tried explaining it.
Hopefully this will get
cleaner and cleaner over time.
So that everybody can just
immediately go, oh, yeah,
you're animating width-- well,
how many elements do you have?
Oh, OK, you're good.
You're good.
You could do that.
So anyway, with
Chrome, you really
can these days, hit 60fps.
So what I want to do
now is try to explain
sort of the logistics of
how to put this together.
Because what we
see a lot is people
just slapping animations and
transitions all over the place,
and sort of hope for the best.
Which I totally
get, because like,
some days you just got
to get it out the door.
The really great
transitions are--
happen when the
people writing them
planned the whole
transition-- the set
of animations running,
as sort of an effect.
So when the finger comes up,
you look at all the things
that you are going
to want to move,
and you get them
all ready to go.
You do any Dom creation that you
need to do for all the things
that are going to need to move.
And then you get them
all going at once.
And you do your nice
animation, and then later you
do some cleanup.
Like maybe you tear
down the old Dom.
And in the middle
there, you try to keep
things relatively clean.
Because you're trying to give
the system as much opportunity
to just make frame
smoothly as it can.
Now there's two really, I
think surprising things,
about these sort of transitions.
The user perceptually
isn't going
to start complaining that
you're laggy, when you lift,
for about 150 milliseconds.
That's a lot longer than 16.
So you can do some substantial
amount of Dom creation,
right after finger up, and
still have people say, oh yeah,
your app is great.
And Topeka, for
example, this thing
that I showed-- this does
a lot of Dom creation,
it's finger ups are
actually quite long.
But you don't notice it.
So let's mentally work
through this situation,
where you want to
have-- you want
to have a card that you tap.
And it's going to go to the
server, and get some data.
And then come back,
and make some Dom.
And then you want
that to appear, right?
A really great way
to structure this,
is to even as you
kick off the XHR,
you start an animation right
away, without the content.
Make the card.
So you saw in Topeka--
that initial demo--
you saw the yellow card grow.
You can get that going and have
be the visual response going,
right away.
This gets the user feeling
like you're responding to them,
even though you don't
know the XHR back.
And then you can use sort of
some web animations and CSS
animations magic, so that
when you do create the Dom,
you don't get any jank.
Let me show you why
that is kind of useful.
Two soccer balls,
they'er both rotating.
The left one is a CSS
animation, that we're
running-- it's a rotate--
transform, rotate right?
The right is just RAF
spinning in JavaScript.
They both can hit 60fps.
Their basically both
about the same speed.
But if I introduce jank on the
main thread, then what happens
is the JavaScript driven one
starts feeling kind of juttery.
And the reason for that is
because the CSS animation
is running off thread.
It's running where
we do that scrolling.
So just like how we were
able to scroll smoothly,
this is a case where the
CSS animation and all
this composite
machinery is actually
kicking in and saving the day.
So when do-- when you
bring this back to the demo
that we're thinking about--
when you do do something
where you're expending
a div to give
a user a sense of appearance
and responsiveness,
if you do it with a pure
transform and scale animation,
you could have a party on
the main thread creating
Dom in the background,
in response thanks XHR,
and still stay
completely smooth.
So the user will experience this
as a great smooth animation,
even though you have
two substantial janks.
One for the finger up, and
one for the create Dom.
But there's this sort
of contract here again,
creeping up on
us, right-- that I
talked about at the beginning,
which is can you represent
the thing you want to do, with
a pure transform and scale?
And the answer is, well, yes, if
your cards are material design,
and you're lucky enough
that all your things are
just flat, with no borders and
no drop shadows for instance,
great, you're good.
But if you're unlucky and you
want a border around this, then
all of a sudden, you
can't do transforms.
You need a width and
height animation.
With sort of the newer builds
of Chrome in 37, et cetera,
this is still totally possible.
When you have GPU raster, the
paint isn't going to kill you.
And because we've sped up
all these individual steps,
you can now get your
XHR back, maybe hold off
your Dom creation, but
then with a RAF loop,
actually tick that height
and width yourself.
And you can even run--
you could decide, oh,
I want to use a width
animation in one direction,
but I want to use inner margin
as my other animation key.
And it'll just work.
And so then you can stage this,
and sort of play games with it.
You keep the main thread
responsive the entire time.
And by keeping the
main thread responsive,
you're able to do all sorts
of sophisticated animations,
using the stuff like height
and width, and so on.
Anyway, this is
like bleeding edge.
We envision that in the future,
we can essentially return
to the way you did animations
of jQuery long ago,
which is you'd say, you know,
dollar blah blah blah, .anim.
And it would just-- you
could pick any CSS property
and it would be
smooth-ish, right?
We want to come back
to that, and not
have to say, no,
no, please decompose
your animation into
these two properties.
That stinks.
So the same sort of
thinking applies to touch.
Pull to refresh, right?
We use it every day
in our mail apps,
and in Twitter, in
social apps-- it's
built into the
mobile experience,
but it's very hard
to do on the web.
And in fact, the
way people do it,
is you do something
like iScroll that
just hijacks scrolling
from the browser.
Where we're going,
is we're trying
to make it possible to do
these touch driven effects
at 60 Hertz, with a touch
move coming right in.
You do all your processing
on the touch move,
and then you do a composite,
and it just runs at 60fps.
There's some people who say
that the way to solve this
is to add a feature
to the web platform,
like a pull to refresh widget.
Frankly, I don't think
we should do that,
because we'll screw it up.
We won't hit every case.
Better to empower JavaScript
to do this, and then
let individual library
authors make great widgets.
And they way to do that, is
to have a sane cost model,
and then have a sane place
where input is delivered.
And then just let
JavaScript run.
And to give you an
example of this working,
this isn't pull to refresh,
this is another widget.
This is a Heidi bars widget.
So you can see these gray
things coming in and out,
as I scroll up and down.
In older Chrome builds and in
most browsers; especially IE,
when you do this,
the scrolling is not
coordinated with
the bar appearing.
They just sort of
race with each other.
And we worked really
hard to make sure
that if you behave, if you
stay responsive in JavaScript,
this will appear coordinated.
So this gives you a
lot of flexibility
to then do whatever effect you
want that's scroll coupled.
You can do pull to refresh too.
I'm not going to get into that.
It's pretty cool though.
Final segment.
So we haven't really been
shy on opinions here.
I haven't been.
we're going to
keep at that this.
And we're always going
to make the translate
and transform based
affects super, super fast.
That is sort of our
bread and butter.
We'll always make that work.
But where we're headed is to
double down on the sort of,
we want to make the full
richness of HTML also
able to hit 60fps.
But before we do that, we've
got some basics to attend to.
This GPU raster thing, the
Magic Viewport's pretty cool.
We want to make it work all
the time without the Magic
Viewport.
And we're going to get to that.
It's just sort of turning the
crank, fixing a lot of bugs.
We know that there's a lot
of dark, unexplored corners
in the platform, where things
don't quite work right.
And a good example is the pinch
viewport-- when you pinch zoom,
position fixed
behaves really weird,
and so you get all
these bad behaviors.
We want to fix that.
We want to make, just when
you have a mobile app,
it just sort of works.
And the old pinch model
doesn't mess you up.
And of course, we're
always working on tools.
You saw these new stuff
coming in DevTools,
you saw the Frame
Viewer, that's eventually
going to show up in DevTools.
So you don't have to
use that tracing tool.
Cool stuff coming there.
But really that bread and
butter, or above about that,
we're going to be pushing
this, and pushing hard.
We're going to try to make
it possible to animate
new kinds of things.
We're going to try to make
it possible do finger couple
effects, without
all sorts of voodoo.
And this is really all
about empowering JavaScript.
We think that having this
compositor thread, that
is the only thing imbibed with
the ability to scroll is crazy.
And we also think that
when you have that model,
you can't have a clearer--
what's fast, what's slow?
We want a clear model.
Anyway, this is
where we're going.
I think what I want
to do is wrap up.
As you go back to your
computer's tomorrow,
the next day, and you sit down,
dig through some prototypes
you did last year or last
week; and try it on our latest
builds, on Canary, on the beta
channel on Chrome Android.
See if it's still slow.
And if it is, keep
some of this in mind.
Let us know what
you think, and then,
start questioning
these fundamentals.
And say, I want-- I want
my app to work like this.
And file bugs
against us, and say,
I want it to work like this.
Chrome, can you fix it?
And we'll be listening.
So anyway, that's what I
have to say for all of you.
Thank you for listening.
And I guess, time for
questions, I suppose.
How do we want to
do questions, Paul?
Do you want to MC?
PAUL: I can try.
NAT DUCA: Yeah.
PAUL: I reckon we have time
for just one or two questions.
Hands up-- oh.
AUDIENCE 1: So
in-- traditionally,
in all browsers, rounded
corners with a small shadow
has been expensive.
Does GPU rastorization or
compositing, whichever it was,
make that a lower
cost operation?
NAT DUCA: Yes.
Different things
become the good thing,
and other things
become the bad thing.
So I believe the verboten
thing at the moment,
on our GPU raster
architecture, is
lots of fonts with
different sizes.
That's the thing
that makes it grumpy.
This stuff changes a lot.
The rounded rex was
particularly bad.
The key thing with
the GPU raster
is it just takes it from
this catastrophic number,
down to sort of a four and five.
So now you're-- instead
of looking at, oh my god,
I've got 300
milliseconds of paint--
kill the rounded corners,
because it'll get 200, right?
Now you're looking
at it like, are we
gonna argue about
two milliseconds?
And sure, we could argue
about two milliseconds.
But it's in a better
and more sane place.
It's more in line with
the other pipeline stages.
And that's what we
really want to do.
PAUL: We're going to have
to wrap up, because of time.
Thank you, Nat.
NAT DUCA: Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]